the ukrainian people are being attacked
from the air from artillery from ground
troops and tanks
the debris of this war litters every
street
but the government has warned for days
of russian saboteurs who've infiltrated
the country to bring terror
death squads who are attacking civilians
in their cars as they flee
they do exist
as we found out
it wasn't something blew up under us
oh there's a big [ __ ] off
stop
where is everyone
where is everyone
here
[Music]
so we identify ourselves
[Music]
is everyone okay
you okay dom
somehow we have to get out of this but
the rounds keep coming it's a
professional ambush
the bullets just don't miss
wow
stop
stop
join the list
join the list
i'm hit but escape the car and with
producer dominic van hidden we make our
way down the embankment
camera operator richie mocker has taken
two rounds to his body armor but is
still stuck in the car where are they
where are you guys
guys
where are you
he runs for it in a hail
the five of us have made it out of the
car down the embankment and we just
can't believe we're alive
okay guys welcome everyone i think i'm
hit
okay yeah
shake
okay
i definitely took something in the back
of my
plate
okay
it's in the car
listen
let's get out of here can you keep going
yes but i think we need to get out of
here
[Music]
but it's really really dangerous
anyway i haven't seen when you get out
i'm certain again
we need to get back up to those cops
so you're bleeding from the head as well
let's go through there behind that wall
connor
we run into a warehouse unit looking for
cover
three caretakers beckon us inside
producer martin val starts coordinating
a rescue plan with skystar
[Music]
crawled well down the side of the thing
she was last security we know any rescue
will take hours
we're stuck
fighting outside we've no idea what's
going on
[Applause]
we've got ourselves into a garage
somehow we found our way in there's
three guys working here and they've said
we can stay with a lot of
firing going on outside
um we don't know why
it appears to be
[Applause]
it's a big fight we might even be on the
front line and we're hoping the military
comes but who knows
i'm going to stop rolling now okay
she's kevin
after a mammoth logistical effort we
were rescued by the local police
we were lucky
thousands of ukrainians are not
and every day this war gets worse here
stuart ramsey sky news